polizei gewalt und rassismus gibt es
schon wir haben das schon millionenfach
gesehen dass ein polizist einen
unschuldigen hungrig
nicht mehr weg
ich habe den schmerz die leidenschaft
und die wut vieler menschen gespürt ich
konnte nicht mehr einfach so
weitermachen
ich musste auf die straße gehen und
protestieren
einfach um gerechtigkeit für george
floyd einzufordern
und für all die anderen opfer von
polizeigewalt
ich wohne in minneapolis 1 1 hat blocks
entfernt von lake street dem
ursprungsort der tester wir konnten
schüsse in der nacht hören
ich vermute dass das gummigeschosse
waren und tränengas am nächsten morgen
entschieden wir uns nachzuschauen was
passiert war
[Musik]
frei
wenn du
das was ich sage hat mich fast zu tränen
gerührt so etwas hätte ich mir in meiner
heimatstadt nie vorstellen können ich
war geschockt und überrascht jemanden in
einem geschäft mit einem sturmgewehr zu
sehen er sagte mir dass er hier steht um
den lagen zu verteidigen
der laden wurde bereits ausgeplündert
ich habe niemanden plündern sehen aber
wenn jemandes versuchen würde würde er
ihnen dann tatsächlich abknallen das ist
eine verrückte situation
[Applaus]
[Musik]
protestierende haben die polizeistation
gestürmt wie für den mord verantwortlich
war
das ist nur eine symbolische und
nachvollziehbare zielscheibe aber wenn
es um die geschäfte geht sieht die
situation anders aus
das ist schwierig zu sagen dass all die
gewalt falsches und gebäude nicht
abgefackelt werden sollte wäre diese
bewegung ohne niedergebrannten gebäude
genauso stark hieß es
[Applaus]
ich verstehe dass die menschen wütend
sind brauchte ich sehe habe auch dass es
eine gruppe von menschen gibt die diese
situation ausnutzen um dinge zu
zerstören ist zu plündern scheiben zu
zerschlagen
autos kaputt zu machen objekte
anzuzünden
dafür habe ich kein verständnis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich erzählte einem einer australischen
freunde das bei uns protestiert wird
er meinte ja was geht denn bei euch ab
daraufhin meinte ich gehe auf meinen
youtube-kanal extreme alles dann kannst
du sehen was ich gerade sehr das einzige
was ich im himmel serie ist
[Musik]
es fühlte sich fast wie in einem film an
die menschen waren am durchdrehen
schaut euch diese karte ist dies ein
protest der partie
[Musik]
wo wir uns befinden das ist kein chicago
es herrschte eine komplette
gesetzlosigkeit in der stadt
ich war schon öfters wir uns alles war
in ordnung er allerdings aber menschen
zu sehen die wie verrückte handeln
das hat mich einfach an mad max
die leute wollen dabei einen service
level auszuplündern ich finde diesen
typen der auf einen geldautomaten
einschlug hinter mir kam es zu einem
streit den habe ich verpasst drehte mich
um und sah nur noch wie eine frau
aufstand
alle hatten etwas in der hand es wurden
überall flaschen geworfen und auf autos
eingeschlagen das einzige was noch
fehlte war eine wüstenlandschaft wenn
wir in der wüste gewesen wären wäre das
zu 100 ich denke dass die menschen die
friedlich protestieren die
aufmerksamkeit der medien bekommen
sollten klar
plünderer sehen die aufmerksamkeit auf
sich weil es verrückt ist aber wir
sollten protestierende und plünderer
auseinanderhalten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du kämpfst kniend für ein anlegen und es
passiert nichts
du fragst nach gerechtigkeit und es
wir haben viele historische ereignisse
erlebt bei denen gesetzes macher gesagt
haben okay wir müssen etwas machen wir
müssen die plünderungen stoppen welche
entscheidung können wir treffen damit es
allen gut geht
ich glaube nicht dass das plündern die
antwort ist aber ich denke dass viel
lärm gemacht werden muss um gehör zu
finden
wir stehen hier vor der polizeistation
[Musik]
wir wachsen im glauben auch dass die
vereinigten staaten das land nummer eins
sind aber in wirklichkeit ist es nicht
so andere länder haben eine allgemeine
gesundheitsversorgung
polizisten tragen keine waffen und die
kriminalitätsrate ist niedrig wir leben
in einem land in dem es wahnsinnig viel
kraft kostet gehört zu finden
viele sachen werden unter den teppich
gekehrt
es wird nach einer
führungspersönlichkeit gesucht dabei
gibt es keine
das ist frustrierend weil wir dieses
tolle land sein sollten in dem der
amerikanische traum möglich ist aber so
einfach ist das nicht
[Musik]
komme gerade aus der u-bahn muss es zu
heiß
ich habe mich entschieden zu
protestieren weil das ausfüllen von
petitionen nicht ausreichend war
ich habe so viele posts veröffentlicht
lustigerweise habe ich erst nach drei
tagen der proteste mitgekriegt dass wir
protestieren
[Musik]
ich stieß auf diesen typen der einfach
einen blutigen kopf hoch ich möchte
nicht über trump reden weil ich nur eine
schimpftirade nach der anderen raus
hauen würde aber mein gefühl war in
diesem moment nebensächlich
die menschen fühlen bei trump was sie
fühlen
sie wandeln die energie um die er
freisetzt und der blutige trump kopf ist
ein paradebeispiel dafür
wir mögen ihn nicht allein sein
auftreten die art und weise wie er sich
benimmt wie er spricht
das ist alles einfach nur krank
[Musik]
wir verlangen nicht dass sie uns mit
auch nicht dass ihr mit uns zufrieden
sein was wir wollen ist die einhaltung
euro versprechen was die gleichheit in
diesem land angeht für alle unabhängig
von der hautfarbe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ende dieses jahres werden wir
weiterhin kämpfen müssen
für das richtige für die gerechtigkeit
für eine verfassung in der wir alle
gleich behandelt werden
ich werde mit vielen anderen es müssen
zigtausende sein wählen gehen wollen wir
den gleichen mann wieder wählen und zu
den gleichen ergebnissen wie in den
letzten vier jahren kommen
oder wollen wir mit einem neuen einen
anderen weg einschlagen um das image von
amerika wieder aufzubauen
die menschen mögen die usa sie sehen sie
als vorbild einen staaten demokratie und
als ort wo viele an den amerikanischen
traum glauben was ist der amerikanische
traum meine eltern sind einwanderer
sie sind hierher bekommen haben ein haus
gekauft autos und alles sie haben mich
und meinen genen durchs college gebracht
mein bruder macht im herbst seinen
abschluss aber all diese sachen haben
keine wirkliche bedeutung weil ich
jederzeit von der polizei angehalten
werden kann und für mich könnte das mein
letzter atemzug sein
es ist unmöglich das leben einer person
wie george floyd zurückzubringen
aber wir können dafür sorgen dass kein
unschuldiger mehr umgebracht wird
wir stimmen dafür wählen wir ins amt
bringen und wer die gesetze
verabschiedet ich freue mich auf die
wahl im november und ich denke viele
leute tun das auch
[Musik]